[Music]
florida primary excited uh it's
happening right now
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
you realize you didn't make a distinct
sound at that point you went num wanna
no the florida primary it's happening as
we speak and uh candidates are pulling
out all the stops to make himself seem
more like a regular guy did you know
this yesterday mitt romney went to a
mcdonald's and ordered burgers and fries
yeah and apparently everything was going
well until mitt romney asked if the
cashier could break a million dollar
bill
let's have this nice guy image
[Applause]
who's on the million dollar bill by the
way mitt romney i should bother
[Laughter]
uh studies are showing that republican
candidates are buying a lot of their ad
time on the weather channel
they're like yeah
you can tell because last night the
weatherman blamed a cold front on
immigration and gay marriage
i thought yeah
[Applause]
could be true i don't know
if you're the latest this is exciting
the government may be legally required
legally required to release the video of
osama bin laden's killing
yeah
president obama said this would be
unhelpful inflammatory and could you
please release it two days before the
election
[Applause]
why did i i don't know what that was
i don't think that's how yeah
well they did we have this amazing
sniper on the show tonight so he will
tell us if i'm wrong but i don't think
that's how seal team yeah
you know that comes seal team six right
now one of their one of their patented
moves one of their patented moves is
tippy-toe yeah
that's a guilty husband coming in late
at night from a strip club not a trains
navy seal
everyone's coming everyone's endorsing
their their candidates roger ebert and
they've been waiting for roger ebert's
opinion
roger ebert has endorsed ron paul
saying he's the only one i'd want to sit
next to on a long airplane flight
that was his reason yeah
so if that's how we're choosing a
president i would like to hereby endorse
the girl from those t-mobile commercials
i'd like to see her
another one
[Applause]
the associated press reports that china
china is greatly expanding its state
television station
yeah this is really good news for
china's number one reality show toddlers
making tiaras
[Applause]
[Music]
new report just came out shows that more
teenagers are switching to twitter
because their parents are on facebook
yeah apparently no teen wants to go
online and catch dad poking mom
a 100 year old woman in the united
kingdom 100 years old has revealed that
her secret to staying sharp is playing a
nintendo ds
sadly no one has the heart to tell her
that's a garage door opener
[Applause]
nbc's in the news nbc's in the news andy
oh i love nbc
please
please
please please water under the bridge
[Music]
nbc
nbc has decided not to air an episode of
fear factor in which contestants drank
donkey seaman
yeah
yeah so this story doesn't have a happy
ending unless you're the donkey
the donkey's
[Music]
you